العلاج بالابر يمكن لأي شخص أن يفعله
بنفسه ويمكن أن يكون فعالًا للغاية
بالنسبة للصداع قصير المدى
بشكل عام.  تشعر بالرضا ولكن ليس
بالضرورة أن تفعل أي شيء من الناحية الطبية ،
فكيف ستتعامل مع
مشكلة شائعة على الطريق ، صداع
، وإذا كان سفرك يتطلب الكثير من
الوقت على قدميك ، يمكنك المشي أو الوقوف
مما يتركك مصابًا بألم أو
تقلصات في الساق أو القدم  في الليل ، قد ترغب
في تجربة تشنجات القدم هذه ، ما تفعله هو
أن تأخذ شفتك السفلية ويمكنك
إما عضها أو مجرد قرصها
وهذا يمكن أن يخفف من تشنج مثل هذا
بشكل مثير للدهشة مدى سرعة أخذ الآخر
للساق  ظفر الإصبع
وبين الشفة العليا والأنف
في المنتصف مباشرة ، هناك نوع من الحفر
لذلك إذا استمرت المشكلة ، فمن الأفضل
أن تتصل بطبيبك في لحظة الصحة اليوم ،
أنا هولي أفضل